two cars are driving towards an
intersection from perpendicular
directions the first cars velocity is 50
kilometers per hour and the second car's
velocity is 90 kilometers per hour at a
certain instant T sub zero the first car
is a distance X sub T sub 0 or X of T
sub zero of half a kilometer from the
intersection and the second car is a
distance Y of T sub 0 of 1.2 kilometers
from the intersection what is the rate
of change of the distance D of T between
the cars at that instant
so at t sub 0 which equation should be
used to solve the problem and they give
us a choice of four equations right over
here so you could pause the video and
try to work through it on your own but
I'm about to do it as well so let's just
draw what's going on that's always a
healthy thing to do so two cars are
driving towards an intersection from
perpendicular directions so let's say
that this is one car right over here and
it is moving in the direct x direction
towards that intersection which is right
over there
and then you have another car that is
moving in the y direction so let's say
it's moving like this so this is the
other car I should have maybe done a top
view well here we go
this square represents the car and it is
moving in that direction now they say at
a certain instant T Sub Zero so let's
draw that instant so the first car is a
distance X of T Sub Zero of 0.5
kilometers so this distance right over
here let's just call this X of T and
let's call this distance right over here
Y of T now how does the distance between
the cars relate to X of T and Y of T
well we could just use the distance
formula which is essentially just the
Pythagorean theorem to say well the
distance between the cars would be the
hypotenuse of this right triangle
remember they're traveling from
perpendicular directions so that's a
right triangle there so this distance
right over here would be X of T squared
plus y
t squared and the square root of that
and that's just the Pythagorean theorem
right over here this would be D of T or
we could say that D of T squared is
equal to X of T X of T squared plus y
let me do any parentheses plus y of T
squared so that's the relationship
between D of T X of T and Y of T and
it's useful for solving this problem
because now we could take the derivative
of both sides of this equation with
respect to T and we'd be using various
derivative rules including the chain
rule in order to do it and then that
would give us a relationship between the
rate of change of D of T which would be
D prime of T and the rate of change of X
of T Y of T and X of T and Y of T
themselves and so if we look at these
choices right over here we in do we
indeed see that D sets up that exact
same relationship that we just did
ourselves that it's it shows that the
the distance squared between the cars is
equal to that x distance from the
intersection squared plus the Y distance
from the intersection squared and then
we can take the derivative of both sides
to actually figure out this related
rates question